dieser Mann kommt aus Seeth eine
710-gemeinde in der es mehr Flüchtlinge
als Einwohner gibt zuerst kam die
Gerüchte also es hieß die Flüchtlinge
kommen wieder kriegt in Russland oder
Russland macht Krieg gegen die Ukraine
es war es zweistimmig war das also sie
ist in der Kaserne da komme ich schon
wieder Flüchtlinge rein einige Sachen
nein um Gottes Willen nicht es wirkt wie
ein eigenes kleines Dorf die
landesunterkunft am Rand von Seeed hier
leben mehr als 800 geflüchtete es gibt
Platz für weitere 200 Berührungspunkte
mit sättern sind selten trotzdem ist das
Verständnis in der Gemeinde hoch
man muss finde ich immer sich einmal
zurücknehmen und sagen mein Gott wenn
ich jetzt selbst Flüchtling wäre und wir
haben ja viele Flüchtlinge die ist auch
noch kennen oder beziehungsweise die
Kinder und Enkelkinder aus Erzählung
was es heißt Flüchtling zu sein dass die
Gemeinde trotz der vielen geflüchteten
gelassen bleibt macht Unbeteiligte
wütend es hagelt Kritik im Netz
ich würde den Leuten die
schlecht reden gerne sagen sollen hier
sonst einmal vor Ort kommen und einmal
schauen weil wir können bis jetzt nichts
negatives sagen
an der Westküste Schleswig-Holsteins
liegt die Gemeinde seht das Ortsbild ist
typisch friesisch Schulen Ärzte und
Einkaufsläden gibt es hier nicht wer
möchte trifft sich beim einzigen Bäcker
einer Gaststätte oder in den Verein auch
die Freiwillige Feuerwehr ist in Seeth
aktiv man kennt sich untereinander viele
wohnen schon seit Jahren hier
ich bin Dennis Andresen ich wohne in Süd
seitdem ich acht bin das in der Gemeinde
geflüchtete Leben ist nichts Neues für
die Väter schon vor acht Jahren waren
hier Asylsuchende untergebracht das hieß
viel Arbeit auch für die Freiwillige
Feuerwehr
2015 2016 standen gemacht
das Gefühl war gemischt was für Menschen
kommen da es waren überwiegend Frauen
und Kinder
und ich sage mal wenn man sich die
Kinder anschaut dann weiß man was die
durchgemacht haben keiner flieht von
seinem Land
freiwillig und kommt hierher nach uns
nach seht wo nichts ist am Rand von seht
eineinhalb Kilometern vom Ortskern
entfernt liegt eine alte Kaserne
umgebaut zur landesunterkunft für
geflüchtete am Eingang gibt es einen
Check-In es wird erfasst wer kommt und
geht 15 Gebäude gehören zur Unterkunft
bei gutem Wetter verbringen viele ihre
Zeit draußen
schlafen und das ist meine Frau Evelina
wir sind schon seit einem Monat mit
unserem Kind hier wir kommen aus Venezia
in der Ukraine
Atem ist der Sohn von Evelina und
Ladislav er ist 12 Jahre alt und geht in
die Schule auf dem Gelände der
landesunterkunft auf dem Stundenplan
heute Deutsch als Zweitsprache
[Musik]
wir lernen hier zahlen und Wörter jetzt
ist unser Thema der Frühling
da bald Ostern ist lernen wir das auch
mit den Mitschülern komme ich ganz gut
klar ich verbringe gerne Zeit mit ihnen
weil wir die gleiche Sprache sprechen
seit März hat die Schule geöffnet über
200 Kinder werden hier unterrichtet der
Schulalltag bietet den Kindern einer
Struktur in ihrem eigenen Tagesablauf
und auch die Möglichkeit
Erlebnisse die sie vielleicht gehabt
haben dass sie ein bisschen
zurückgedrängt werden und sie sich mit
anderen Dingen befassen können
in diesem Moment nicht vernachlässigen
darf nach der Schule hilft Atem seinem
Vater in der Fahrradwerkstatt eigentlich
ist Wallis love Musiker jetzt repariert
er zusammen mit einem Kollegen
ausrangierte dratinsel jeden Tag
arbeitet er fünf Stunden und bekommt
dafür ein kleines Taschengeld wladislav
möchte sich gerne nützlich machen die
geflüchteten können die Fahrräder
ausleihen
ich arbeite hier damit die Leute ihre
Freizeit gut gestalten oder auch mal in
den Supermarkt fahren können falls man
etwas braucht
ich weiß wie man Fahrräder repariert und
ich bin mir sicher dass das hier allen
zugute kommt
vor Ort gibt es auch eine ärztliche
Betreuung um die Praxen in den
umliegenden Städten zu entlasten das
Wartezimmer ist voll jeden Tag kommen
bis zu 150 geflüchtete hierher der
Impfstatus aller wird überprüft je nach
Beschwerden kann das Praxisteam schnell
reagieren es gibt unter anderem ein EKG
leichte Medikamente und eine
psychologische Betreuung vor Ort die
Menschen die zu uns kommen aus aller
Herren Länder kennen unser System nicht
und wissen nicht wo und wie sie am
besten und schnellsten eine medizinische
Versorgung bekommen können insofern ist
es sinnvoll die medizinische Versorgung
und Berg dort zu haben wo die Menschen
auch untergebracht sind wo sie schlafen
wir merken tatsächlich dass die Menschen
die zu uns kommen als Patienten auch
unsere Fürsorge und unsere Stützung auch
wertschätzen durchaus sehr sehr
vorteilhaft und sehr sehr warmherzig
in Haus und Evelina mit ihrer Familie es
ist ein Gebäude extra für Personen mit
Haustieren ihre Hündin Roxy haben sie
aus der Ukraine mitgebracht die
Einrichtung ist karg lange werden sie
hier nicht mehr bleiben
in zwei Wochen müssen wir schon in
Rendsburg sein und ich hoffe dass dort
auf uns eine neue Zukunft wartet eine
friedlichere mit mehr Perspektive
die Familie ist zuversichtlich
sie haben bereits im Ausland gelebt
beschreiben sich als kommunikative
Menschen
[Musik]
wir versuchen so oft es geht aus dem
Camp rauszukommen und in der nahe
gelegenen Nachbarschaft spazieren zu
gehen um mehr zu sehen und die Sprache
besser zu verstehen
die Kommunikation mit den Menschen hilft
dabei dass wir uns anders normale Leben
hier gewöhnen
Feuerwehrmann Dennis und mit seiner
Familie 20 Minuten zu Fuß von der
landesunterkunft entfernt er und seine
Frau engagieren sich im Ort sie sind gut
vernetzt
ich bin Annika Andresen und wohne seit
23 Jahren hier seht
die Familie hat Kleider und Spielzeug
für die geflüchteten gespendet direkte
Berührungspunkte haben sie aber kaum sie
leben weiter wie gewohnt man sieht die
dann mal spazieren laufen und wir hatten
auch ein Dorffest da durften die auch
kommen da war aber dann auch keiner da
Laterne laufen wurde von der Feuerwehr
angeboten da waren dann letztendlich ein
paar Kinder mit den Betreuern
ja aber sonst eher weniger morgens wenn
ich im Bus bin da sitzen mal viele
Flüchtlinge drinne mit Koffern und so
und wie ist das für dich
man muss halt schauen dass man auf die
Plätze kommt weil die ganzen Koffer da
sind aber die sind auch nett und wenn da
kein Platz ist dann machen die Platz
dass man damit sitzen kann auf dem
Platzen
damit Konflikte gar nicht erst entstehen
können ist der Bürgermeister der
Gemeinde im ständigen Austausch mit der
landesunterkunft
im Sommer sehe ich gewisse Gefahren dass
wir an den Stränden an den flussbädern
in Eider und Träne da eventuell paar
Probleme kriegen können wir hatten
gestern einen Round Table dort wurde den
besprochen dass die Polizei
vermehrt darauf achtet jetzt also die
werden Streife fahren die werden auch am
Strand präsent sein und Beziehung wenn
ich Polizei nicht dann werden die
Hilfskräfte der der landesunterkunft
dort vorbeischauen um das etwas zu
entfernen das Konflikte ausbleiben und
die Situation vor Ort akzeptiert wird
sorgt im Netz für Diskussion es heißt
man würde in sät noch Aufwachen die
Kriminalität werde steigen auf Nachfrage
woher die Aussagen kommen gibt es keine
Antwort Verständnis dafür gibt es vor
Ort nicht ich sehe im Moment keine
Gefahr dass die Stimmung kippt natürlich
haben wir das nie ganz in der Hand das
hängt auch von den Menschen ab die zu
uns kommen wie die sich verhalten hier
aber wir tun alles dafür dass wir eine
gute Stimmung in der Unterkunft haben
deshalb bin ich optimistisch auch für
die Zukunft wir selber begreifen wissen
es gar nicht also warum die so viel
Interesse an uns ist
wir behandeln unsere ich sag jetzt
Mitbürger ganz normal als Bürger sie
gehören jetzt unsere Ortschaft
feuerwehrtechnisch sind wir
verantwortlich für die
und
für uns ist es hier normal eigentlich
ein Miteinander zu leben und es ist egal
von wo man kommt
seit einem Jahr leben seter und
geflüchtete wieder an einem Ort
Erfahrung aus dem vergangenen Jahren
wurden genutzt Konfliktpotenzial wird
eingedämmt es ist eine Koexistenz die
funktioniert die beispielhafte Akzeptanz
ist was die Gemeinde ausmacht